une prouesse chirurgicale c'est à
l'hôpital edouard herriot de lyon qu'une
équipe franco australienne a réussi à
greffer une main un homme
une opération qui s'est bien déroulée
elle avait été préparée de longue date
images de cette première des images en
exclusivité pour france télévisions
documents commentés par christine le
héros il y a deux jours encore cet homme
d'affaires australien clint hallam
n'avait qu'une seule main valide il ya
neuf ans il a été amputé suite à un
accident avec une circulaire samarra
avait été greffé mais sans succès il
n'avait pas retrouver la sensibilité et
bien sûr le mouvement il a voulu tenter
cette première mondiale
je suis vraiment très ému d'avoir cette
opportunité d'être le premier clint
hallam a fait le déplacement jusqu'à
lyon accompagné des spécialistes
australiens les plus grand soin sont
prodigués lors du transport de la main
d'une personne en fait décédé pour
réaliser cette opération plein d'avenir
il a fallu un donneur compatible extrême
concentration dans la salle d'opération
c'est la première fois qu'un membre d'un
donneur est ainsi greffé les équipes
françaises et australiennes ont effectué
un travail de titan ils ont fixé les
deux principaux os de l'avant bras puis
minutieusement ils ont suture et les
artères plus les veilles une à une enfin
les nerfs chaque fibre nerveuse l'une
après l'autre les chirurgiens à
attendait ce jour depuis très longtemps
je rêvais de cette intervention depuis
je rêvais à deux avec le chirurgien le
micro chirurgie australien experts les
amis de toujours nous avons pu réaliser
ce rêve mais je crois aussi que c'est un
rêve qui hante l'esprit de
de l'homme depuis plus longtemps je
donne beaucoup d'espoir à tous ceux qui
sont victimes d'accidents domestiques du
travail de des mines antipersonnel à
tous ceux qui y sont nés avec des
malformations congénitales clint hallam
a tenté l'opération c'est un succès les
chirurgiens satisfait mais prudent
demande encore quelques semaines avant
de tirer un bilan voir s'il ya un
phénomène de rejet ou non voir aussi
bien sûr si la sensibilité et le
mouvement reviennent parfaitement